we ask if you are able to
please rise and remove your caps
in joining major league baseball the
miami marlins
and the philadelphia phillies as we
remember
those whose lives were lost on september
11
2001 we paid tribute to them
and to the men and women who serve our
country
as we honor the pledge we shall
not forget rogers fourth major league
start a career high
ten strikeouts in his last outing
against the rays
second marlins started to get to ten
strikeouts
other than six doe sanchez those two
guys boy oh boy
a little glimpse into the future here
for the marlins mccutcheon hitting 243
with with five home runs 24 runs better
today one for five last night and he
lines one into left field of base hit
he's gonna have an extra base hit right
out of the gate
that's a good start for the fighting
phils at second base and here's reese
reese was one for five last night with a
single
trevor kicks deals swinging a miss
struck him out
strikeout number one on the night for
trevor rogers
that brings harper up batting 254. 145
average
over the course of his last 20 games and
a called strike three
so two strikeouts after the leadoff
double rogers looking good early
mccutchen at second for jt real mutual
after a lead off double from andrew
mccutchen
rogers struck out the next three hoskins
harper and rio muto
noah four and three two point seven four
earned run average looking for him to
bounce back tonight
i'm not saying he's gotta throw a
complete game tom but he's got to go
seven
aaron against the marlins three and
seven for his career
swing and a miss he does go back to the
change up marta last night
three for five with a couple of doubles
so i gotta miss change up again so he's
gotten two strikeouts on the changeup
matt joyce playing in right field again
batting 272.
swing it a miss got the curve ball
working there
three strikeouts for nola here's brian
anderson batting 254.
swing gonna miss another strikeout with
the curveball here's garrett cooper with
two down and nobody on
d-h-ing tonight batting 278 yes he did
i think he did joe west thinks he did
too and aaron just struck out the side
he has five strikeouts through two adam
hazley now with one out
and hazley getting the start against the
guy he was a drafted in front of six
picks ahead of trevor rogers in that
first round in 2017.
lines that one out toward right center
field that's going to be an extra base
hit a one hop off the wall
that adam's gonna pull into second base
with his fourth double of the year
here is andrew mccutchen
mccutchen hits one a deep left field no
doubt about that one
it is gone into the first row going
after the first pitch and the phillies
are on top two nothing
yeah i think andrew's seen the ball
pretty good off rogers home run number
six for mccutchen
26 runs batted in here's gene suguro
with a couple of runners on and two outs
pulled to left field and there's your
extra base hit ben riesel score real
button runs well
he's already being waved home from third
and he's on his way and he'll score it's
a two run double for segora
and the phillies have scored four runs
in the inning it'll be first and third
with nobody out
that'll bring up adam haisley's now two
for
four in the series ground ball through
the hole on the right side haisley's two
for two that's an rbi
single and the phillies leading five
nothing and here's andrew mccutchen
who's also
two for two with a double and a homer
mccutchen lines one out to left center
field that'll be in for a base hit
and boom's around third he's heading for
home no throw
over to third base goes hazely rbi
single
and it's now six nothing and runners on
the corners for the fill still nobody
out of the inning
that one's hooked down the left field
line and it is gone
into the second row a three-run
home run and reece has busted this baby
open
it's now nine-nothing phillies
go down and get it reece that might be
the lowest pitch rhys has ever hit
i mean that was beautiful home run
number ten he's back within one
of real muto for the club lead still
don't have a hit in this game they've
had just one base runner
marte one of the offensive stars last
night on two pitch is a fastball oh
and he swung did he say he swung
yes he did well arenal with eight
strikeouts
one gone bring up alec baum
pulls that one they use the whole field
there the whole left field line
deeney on his way to third and he's
going to be waved home
and alec bohm is going to have an rbi
double
it's now 10 nothing phillies and boehm
is two for three here's adam hazley and
the 2-2 pitch
pulled down the right field line that'll
be another extra base hit for haisley
balm will score easily and hazely on his
way to second base
is their standing an rbi double
back-to-back doubles it's 11-nothing
phillies
this will be the 10th pitch of the
at-bat to brian anderson as he leads off
the fifth inning
and he pulls it past baum into left
field first hit of the day
for the marlins and it'll bring garrett
cooper up
out towards short should be two there's
one and
two here's the second hit of the game
two down here's chisholm
swig miss nine strikeouts for aaron nola
so here's harrison his first at-bat
after he replaced marte in
center he's the 2-2 from nolta and a
swing and a miss he struck him out
there's number 10 on the night for aaron
nola
back-to-back double-digit strikeout
games for the phil's right-hander it's a
one
two three six all right so now are noah
goes to work
if he finishes this inning off it would
be a complete game his first
of his career that one's to the left of
the mound flagged down by nola
there are two outs that's a heck of a
play who said pitchers aren't athletes
so rudders on first and second and here
is issan diaz who singled off the middle
and is only at bat
back the runner at second base and the
2-2 pitch
and a line drive caught by d.d gregorius
and aaron noah has his first complete
game
shutout of what is a budding career for
the phillies right-hander and man did
the phillies need this
they win it today by a final score of 11
to nothing